l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion en
application de l'article 34 alinéa 1 de
la constitution de la proposition de
résolution portant sur la reconnaissance
et la condamnation de la grande famille
de
1932-1933 connu sous le nom dolodomor
comme génocide avant de commencer la
discussion je tiens à saluer la présence
dans les tribunes de Monsieur Vadim
homelchenko ambassadeur du crâne en
France
nous allons donc ouvrir la discussion
générale avec Madame angente pour le
groupe Renaissance et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre Monsieur l'Ambassadeur mes
chers collègues
ce dont je veux vous parler et l'exemple
le plus classique du génocide soviétique
l'expérimentation la plus achevée en
matière de russification la destruction
de la nation ukrainienne ces mots ne
sont pas les miens je les emprunte à
Raphaël Lemkin juriste à l'origine du
concept de génocide il les avait
prononcé lors d'une conférence
commémorant le 20e anniversaire de Lolo
de mort
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre Monsieur l'Ambassadeur chers
collègues ce dont je veux vous parler
aujourd'hui et l'histoire d'une barbarie
organisée d'une brutalité absolue un pan
de notre histoire collective celui de
l'Ukraine d'abord et de la nôtre ensuite
une histoire qui débute en 1929 avec
l'ordre de Joseph Staline d'une
collectivisation et d'une
industrialisation à marche forcée de
l'URSS cette politique dite du grand
tournant se traduit alors dans les
campagnes soviétiques et donc en Ukraine
par une réquisition sans limite des
récoltes avec expropriation arrestation
et déportation des propriétaires
terriens appelés kulac
une histoire qui se poursuit en Ukraine
en 1930 privé de toute leur récolte et
même de toutes leurs semences les
paysans se soulèvent plus aucune moisson
n'est possible pas un morceau de pain la
fin s'installe un exode rural commence
et bien entendu la production de blé
s'effondre
alors elle était 1932 Stanis s'emporte
et donne un ordre clair le plus
important maintenant dit-il c'est
l'Ukraine si nous nomme trop prenons pas
immédiatement le redressement de la
situation nous pouvons perdre l'Ukraine
il a bien dit perdre l'Ukraine sa
décision terrible et prise utilisez
l'arme de la fin contre les paysans
Ukrainiens les frontières sont fermées
le moindre grain de blé est traqué des
villages et des fermes sont délibérément
bloquées le commerce est arrêté des
impôts supplémentaires sont prélevés
dans les premiers mois de 1933 l'Ukraine
grenier de blé est devenu terre de sang
chaque jour des milliers de paysans
Ukrainiens meurent affamés leur corps
jonge rue et chant
cette famine méticuleusement organisée
par Staline rappelons-le prend alors
l'appellation dolodomor l'extermination
par la fin
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre Monsieur l'Ambassadeur cher
collègue ce dont je vous ai parlé n'est
rien d'autre que l'utilisation de la
famille comme arme politique pour briser
la résistance d'un peu pour l'effacer de
la carte et le privé d'une conscience
nationale qui s'éveillait à l'époque
face à ces millions de morts un silence
le nôtre celui des dirigeants
occidentaux qui comme le soulignait le
journaliste Gareth Jones je le cite
regardait ailleurs
regardez ailleurs
effrayé par l'Allemagne nazie et bien
trop soucieux d'importer des milliers de
tonnes de blé aujourd'hui la guerre
totale menée en Ukraine par le Kremlin
replace l'histoire sous notre regard car
ce que nous observons est une nouvelle
tentative de négation du fait national
ukrainien avec l'annexion de territoires
des déportations d'enfants des crimes de
guerre commis contre la population ou
encore le colo de mort ce nom écho donné
au ciblage des infrastructures
énergétiques civiles pour faire mourir
de froid mourir de froid la population
ukrainienne chacune de ces agressions
est une atteinte à nos valeurs les plus
chères et fait ressurgir pour les
Ukrainiens le spectre de ce traumatisme
passé alors madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur mes chers collègues
histoire
devoir de mémoire
identité
opposant à l'arme passée de la fin celle
de la reconnaissance et du souvenir
chers collègues nous avons ici une
responsabilité celle de faire connaître
de reconnaître et de condamner car votez
pour cette résolution c'est aussi
confirmée aux Français aux Européens et
au monde que lorsque les valeurs
essentielles et universelles sont en jeu
il n'y a plus ni majorité ni minorité ni
centre ni droite ni gauche mais une
Assemblée nationale composée de femmes
et d'hommes qui représentent la nation
tout entière et qui réunit dans un même
élan d'humanité vote en conscience alors
ne regardons plus ailleurs vive
l'Ukraine libre je vous remercie merci
Madame
la parole est à Monsieur Frédéric Falcon
pour le groupe rassemblement national et
pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
chers collègues deux ans il a fallu deux
ans à l'Union soviétique pour commettre
un crime de masse dont on parle encore
près d'un siècle plus tard deux ans pour
marquer d'une cicatrice bérante toute
une nation pour le grenier à blé pour de
Vienne une terre de sang fin des
portations goulag camp de concentration
grand de purge exécution voilà les mots
qui résument l'air soviétique ne
l'oublions pas c'est une idéologie
communiste qui responsable de millions
de morts et qui a conduit exterminer un
peuple qui commençait à résister au
modèle collectiviste qui lui était
brutalement imposé
la vérité est là l'histoire nous montre
que tout régime communiste prend les
traits d'une dictature l'application du
communisme portant lui les germes de
l'autoritarisme et conduit
malheureusement au pire des rives
destructrices
ce sont les raisons pour lesquelles nous
devons condamner ces actes espérons-le
encore une fois que de tels actes ne
soient jamais à nouveau commis
l'État soviétique est responsable de
crimes contre l'humanité ce sont les
Ukrainiens kazakh russes qui en ont été
les victimes
aujourd'hui c'est une proposition vise à
reconnaître et à condamner Lolo de mort
ce crime contre l'humanité et la
conséquence de la mise en place par
l'État soviétique de la collectivisation
par les cols causes cette
collectivisation ciblant tous les
paysans et particulièrement les
Ukrainiens consistait en la confiscation
ou pour on pourrait même dire le vol par
l'État communiste de plus de 40% de leur
récolte
les paysans déjà affamés par leur propre
gouvernement dans un mouvement de
justice légitime ce sont ainsi révoltés
la répression est alors terrible les
velléités d'indépendance sont alors
écrasées
les koulaks sont privés de leur liberté
la collectivisation forcée continue ils
sont affamés c'est alors tout le pays
qui agonise Joseph Winkler dans son
œuvre intitulé l'Ukrainienne retranscrit
le témoignage suivant en janvier 1931 la
famine a commencé à l'automne précédent
il y avait suffisamment de blé ce
n'était pas une mauvaise année
les chefs de kolkos qui expropriés les
paysans leur prenaient aussi les
céréales qui jetées par tonne dans le
diap ils ont causé artificiellement
cette famine pour que les gens aillent
travailler au kolkhoz s'il ne voulaient
pas mourir de faim parce que la cantine
leur donnait du pain de la soupe pour
les journées de travail rien de plus
ainsi au printemps d'innocent près de
40% des Ukrainiens sont emportés par la
famine Union soviétique a bien tenté de
dissimuler ses crimes tout comme le
Parti communiste français de l'époque
mais la vérité éclatera au grand jour la
famille ne planifiait la privation des
libertés les impositions lourdes les
confiscations des récoltes du bétail et
des semis Annie Le tout-existants ce
paysannes 90 ans après la famille le
bilan est évalué à 6 millions de morts
voilà l'horreur de Lolo de mort
reconnaître aujourd'hui ce crime contre
l'humanité le symbole de le condamnation
des atrocités de l'idéologie communiste
dans sa volonté de faire vivre un grand
soir à tous les peuples l'empire
soviétique enchaînera les crimes contre
l'humanité c'est une proposition de
résolution à la vertu de dénoncer les
atrocités commises par le régime
soviétique et d'ouvrir un débat bienvenu
sur la nature même du communisme le
chemin est encore long avant la pleine
reconnaissance internationale de toute
la souffrance vécue par les peuples
si les historiens tergivers se sont
l'application de la définition juridique
du génocide une chose est certaine c'est
mignon de morts sont les résultats de la
politique de l'Union des républiques
socialistes soviétiques et en mémoire de
ses peuples affamés détruit nous
voterons cette résolution je vous
remercie merci
la parole est à Monsieur Bastien Lachaud
pour le groupe la France insoumise nue
et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente chers collègues
entre 1930 et 1933 près de 7 millions de
citoyens des républiques soviétiques
sont morts de fin 1,5 millions en Russie
1,5 millions au Kazakhstan 4 millions en
Ukraine ou ces événements sont désignés
sous le nom Holodomor
90 ans après les faits la plaie béante
ouverte par ce drame n'est pas refermée
un demi-siècle durant la vérité fut
étouffée par les autorités soviétiques
conserver seulement grâce aux patients
travail de mémoire de la diaspora
ukrainienne aujourd'hui le durcissement
du régime autocratique de Vladimir
Poutine s'accompagne de nouvelles
tentatives d'effacer la réalité de
millions de morts nier c'est tué une
seconde fois comment ne pas comprendre
l'aspiration des décédants des
descendants des victimes et de tout un
peuple à la reconnaissance s'ouvre donc
la question des termes et des modalités
de cette reconnaissance nul ne peut nier
la réalité du crime nul ne peut
minimiser son ampleur monstrueuse inouï
nul ne peut mettre en doute l'existence
d'une intentionnalité de la part de
Staline et des dirigeants soviétiques
après avoir lancé la collectivisation de
l'agriculture à marche forcée lorsqu'il
réprime à brutalement toute résistance
paysanne lorsqu'il réquisitionna les
récolte va pouvoir stalinien provocat
puis aggrava délibérément la famine la
mort de millions d'hommes de femmes et
d'enfants crimes de masse crimes contre
l'humanité assurément
génocide la communauté scientifique et
partagée les historiens ne donnent pas
tous la même décision de ce concept
Timothy Snyder éminent historien
États-Unis soutien de la cause
ukrainienne face à l'agression russe
écrit dans son grand livre terre de sang
publiée en 2010 je préfère tuerie de
masse à génocide en raison des
controverses inévitables et insolubles
suscité par ce terme sur le plan
juridique
fait hôtel adopté
par leur des Nations Unies
le 148 elle repose sur deux critères
l'intentionnalité et la volonté de
détruire un groupe national ethnique
racial ou religieux comme tel c'est ce
second critère qui constitue le point
d'achoppement du débat
assurément en Ukraine la répression des
résistances paysannes à la
collectivisation fut plus terrible
encore qu'ailleurs
Staline voulait écraser toute
renaissance d'un mouvement national
ukrainien mais s'agissait-il
d'exterminer le peuple ukrainien en tant
que tel
dans les campagnes ukrainiennes les
victimes de la famille ne furent pas
uniquement des Ukrainiens des milliers
de citoyens soviétiques de nationalités
russes juives ou allemande mourutent
aussi de faim par ailleurs une grande
partie des bourreaux dirigeants
communistes ou activistes de base
étaient eux
ukrainien la différence est flagrante
avec les trois génocides reconnus comme
tel par l'ONU le génocide arménien la
Shoah et le génocide des Tutsi au Rwanda
Anne Apple bauhome journaliste et
historienne elle aussi engagée en
soutien à l'Ukraine écrit ainsi dans
famine rouge publié en 2017 et qui fait
autorité tel que définit dans les
documents des Nations Unies génocide
devraient désigner l'élimination
physique de tout un groupe ethnique
comme dans l'Holocauste Holodomor ne
répond pas à ce critère
en reconnaissant au lot de mort comme un
génocide notre assemblée remettrait
ainsi en cause la définition de l'ONU et
ce de façon unilatérale une telle
décision est lourde de conséquences
morales scientifique politique
elle remettrait en cause la singularité
des trois génocides reconnus comme tel
par l'humanité entière elle ouvrirait la
porte à la reconnaissance unilatérale de
multiples autres génocides au gré des
conflits et guerres que les États se
livrent devant l'opinion mondiale
en somme
au nom d'un impératif politique présent
que nous partageons affirmer notre
soutien à l'Ukraine face à l'agression
criminelle du régime de Vladimir Poutine
la présente résolution nous invite à
nous arroser le droit d'écrire
l'histoire et elle nous fait courir le
risque de déchirer le délicat tissu du
droit international notre sens des
responsabilités nous interdit de
franchir ce pas c'est pourquoi nous ne
prendrons pas par au vote
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur michel Herbillon pour le groupe
les républicain et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre monsieur
l'Ambassadeur mes chers collègues notre
assemblée aujourd'hui réunie pour
débattre de la proposition de résolution
portant sur la reconnaissance et la
condamnation de la Grande Famine de 1932
Ukraine connu sous le nom de l'eau de
mort comme génocide
dans la continuité de la proposition de
résolution largement adoptée affirmant
le soutien de l'Assemblée nationale à
l'Ukraine et condamnant la guerre
d'agression menée par la Russie avant
dernier le test le texte discutait
aujourd'hui et le bienvenu pour
renouveler une fois de plus notre
attention et notre profond soutien à
l'égard du peuple ukrainien qui à
travers l'histoire a subi tant de drames
car oui en France peu de nos
compatriotes aux connaissances de la
famine dévastatrice orchestrée par les
autorités soviétiques à l'encontre des
paysans notamment
Ukrainiens qui se sont révoltés contre
la collectivisation forcée des terres
agricoles et la réquisition des récoltes
celle-ci a débuté en 1929 avec
l'avènement du grand tournant décidé par
Joseph Staline qui Orchestra la
collectiviste la collectivisation forcée
et les expropriations des propriétaires
terriens
décision majeure de la terreur
stalinienne les faire bécoopératives
sont nationalisés et placés sous
l'autorité de l'État soviétique au sein
desquelles près de 30% des récoltes
étaient prélevées face à ces mesures la
paysanne rue ukrainienne s'est soulevée
dès le début des années 30 et a subi la
répression des autorités soviétiques qui
craignaient la résurgence d'un
nationalisme ukrainien alors même que
des difficultés alimentaires des
populations étaient signalées les
autorités soviétiques ont augmenté les
réquisitions des récoltes et ont entre
fin octobre 32 et janvier 1933
intensifié sévèrement la répression
emprisonnement déportation Sibérie ou
dans les camps du Goulag interdiction de
déplacement pour les paysans sont des
exemples de cette terrible répression
pire encore la décision d'instaurer des
districts mis au tableau noir au mois de
janvier 1933 dans la moitié des cols
causes et villages Ukrainiens a eu pour
conséquence le retrait des magasins de
tous les produits manufacturés
alimentaires l'arrêt total du commerce
le remboursement immédiat de tous les
crédits en cours et la mise en place
d'une imposition exceptionnelle
spoliatrice les conséquences sont
dramatiques et entraîné la mort
d'environ 4 millions du craignent
affamés en raison de la répression
délibérée des autorités soviétiques
cette barbarie a un nom au lot de mort
extermination par la fin alors que la
majorité des historiens et des experts
en droit international s'accorde
aujourd'hui pour affirmer que le lot de
mort est un acte de génocide causé
intentionnellement pour réprimer la
résistance des paysans et contrôler la
population
ukrainienne cette mémoire a longtemps
été tue en France et dans le monde
aujourd'hui encore cette témoins est
contestée par la Fédération de Russie
dont les armées ont démantelé le 19
octobre dernier dans la ville occupée de
Mario Paul un monument commémorant cette
grande famille
dans ce contexte de la guerre
d'agression menée par la Russie à
l'encontre de l'Ukraine je veux saluer
cette proposition de résolution
transpartisane portée par notre collègue
anjante alors que le Parlement ukrainien
a reconnu cette famille de comme
génocide en 2006 que le Bundes staga
allemand et le Parlement européen ont
eux aussi reconnu le caractère
génocidaire de ces crimes en novembre et
décembre dernier je crois qu'il est
l'heure pour l'Assemblée nationale de se
joindre à ses parlements il en va en
effet notre responsabilité d'affirmer
haut et fort que face au crime d'hier et
au crime d'aujourd'hui la communauté
internationale ne se thérapeute et
condamnera avec la plus grande fermeté
de tels actes pour l'ensemble de ces
raisons les républicains voteront en
faveur de cette proposition de
résolution dont nous espérons qu'elle
sera votée à l'unanimité par notre
assemblée elle est un magnifique symbole
de notre reconnaissance à l'égard du
peuple ukrainien durablement par les
crimes de l'Union soviétique et un appel
humaniste adressé au monde entier de ne
plus tolérer de condamner de telles
actes barbares aussi le vote de cette
résolution par l'Assemblée nationale
s'inscrit bien évidemment dans le
contexte de la guerre d'agression menée
par la Russie contre l'Ukraine en effet
Vladimir Poutine n'a cessé depuis le
début de la guerre de nier l'identité et
l'indépendance ukrainienne en
s'affranchissant de toutes les vérités
historiques pour justifier les pires
atrocités cette situation fait
malheureusement écho à la période connu
lors de Lolo de mort et au mensonge
proférés par les autorités soviétiques
ainsi le message qui est envoyé
aujourd'hui par l'Assemblée nationale
est essentielle pour exprimer notre
intransigence et notre volonté farouche
de soutenir et de défendre le peuple
ukrainien qui se bat avec tant de
courage pour cette liberté et pour
défendre les valeurs qui nous sont
communes merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Madame Maud Gatel pour
le groupe démocrate et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur mes chers
collègues
le passé rejoint aujourd'hui le présent
oui le passé rejoint aujourd'hui le
présent car nous étudions une
proposition de résolution
transpartisanale à l'initiative de ma
collègue Anne gente sur la
reconnaissance de Lolo de mort comme
génocide qui éclaire si tristement ce
que vivent depuis le 24 février dernier
nous a mis ukrainiens et c'est aussi
face aux atrocités du présent que l'on
prend conscience de l'importance de ce
confronter et de reconnaître l'effet du
passé
Lolo de mort littéralement
l'extermination par la fin qui a frappé
l'Ukraine il y a 90 ans et l'histoire
méconnue d'une tragédie orchestrée par
le régime totalitaire soviétique ce
crime de masse a délibérément ciblé les
paysans ukrainiens et à travers eux
l'ensemble de la nation ukrainienne dans
la volonté de l'anéantir
est longtemps demeurer tu dissimulé par
le pouvoir stalinien mais également par
les populations victimes durablement
traumatisées il a également fait l'objet
d'arbitrage géopolitique d'aucun
privilégiant la construction d'une paie
inachevée aux dépens de la
reconnaissance des crimes passés cette
famille organisée par le totalitarisme
stalinien pourrait avoir causé plusieurs
millions de morts en Ukraine jusqu'à 10
millions si l'on tient compte des
victimes hors du territoire ukrainien
notamment au Kazakhstan des millions de
victimes morts de faim résultat de
l'échec de la politique de
collectivisation forcée lancée par
Staline au début des années 30 pour
moderniser l'URSS mais résultat
également de mesures délibérées visant à
affamés le peuple ukrainien
le régime soviétique a ainsi prélevé
dans le Grenouillet à blé de l'Europe
d'énormes quantités de grains et face à
la résistance des Ukrainiens Staline et
son entourage ont décidé d'accentuer la
répression interdisant l'exode des
familles ukrainiennes qui tentaient de
fuir vers les villes pour trouver de
quoi se nourrir alors que Vladimir
Poutine n'hésite jamais instrumentaliser
l'histoire pour justifier sa guerre et
renforcer son pouvoir la reconnaissance
et la condamnation de mort en tant que
génocide revêtent une importance toute
particulière sans instrumentaliser avec
toutes les arrières pensées possibles le
droit international
si la réalité de la famine est reconnue
désormais la question de sa
qualification peut demeurer pas pour
nous qui assumons de parler de génocides
dans la lignée des historiens comme
Andrea graciosi Barbara Martin Nicolas
verte ou romane Serbie bien sûr tous les
génocides ne sont pas identiques mais
ils ont bien des caractéristiques
communes ou trop les faits des millions
de morts par la famille
l'intentionalité des actions menées par
Moscou suffisamment et indiscutablement
documenté démontre le caractère
génocidaire de la grande famine
ces actions savamment orchestrées
constituent une volonté délibérée du
pouvoir soviétique de punir et
d'exterminer la nation ukrainienne en
tant qu'ensemble politique parce que son
opposition à sa politique menaçait
l'unité et l'existence de l'URSS
Rafael Lemkin l'inventeur du terme
génocide comme la rappeler annegente
parler de trois génocides le génocide
arménien la Shoah et Lolo de mort il
considère que l'intention de Staline
était bien l'anéantissement de la nation
ukrainienne à travers d'abord la
destruction de l'intelligentia
ukrainienne de l'église puis des paysans
à travers la famille organisée
comme le Parlement européen est presque
30 parlements nationaux avant nous
j'aurais aimé que notre assemblée
reconnaisse et condamne unanimement
cette tragique de l'histoire pour ce
qu'elle est un génocide car ce devoir
nous incombe pour honorer la mémoire des
victimes de ce crime de masse
cette reconnaissance doit s'accompagner
également du ouverture des archives les
historiens doivent pouvoir continuer
documenter les faits pour que le lot de
bord ne soit plus un angle mort de
l'histoire
le moment où intervient l'examen de
cette proposition de résolution n'est
évidemment pas anodin et nous l'assumons
dans le contexte de la guerre en Ukraine
reconnaître et condamner le génocide de
Lolo de mort constitue un soutien au
peuple ukrainien dont la reconnaissance
des crimes de masse perpétré à son
endroit par le régime soviétique mais
c'est aussi un puissant message
politique que nous envoyons à l'Ukraine
pour la soutenir dans sa résistance face
à l'agresseur russe pour toutes ces
raisons le groupe démocrate votera en
faveur de cette résolution je vous
remercie
merci madame la députée la parole est à
Monsieur Alain David pour le groupe
socialiste et apparenté pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur
monsieur le ministre monsieur
l'Ambassadeur monsieur le président de
la commission des affaires étrangères
chers collègues il n'est pas toujours
simple pour notre assemblée de s'emparer
de sujets mémorial
les députés longs par exemple fait
par la reconnaissance du génocide contre
le peuple arménien en 1998 à
l'initiative de René Rouquet et à
nouveau en 2001 à celle de François
Rochebloine dans un processus législatif
hasardeux et heurté nous aurons
apparemment prochainement à le faire
également sur la proposition de
résolution relative au massacre des
Algériens le 17 octobre
1961 à Paris
pourtant le sujet qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui et de notre ordre bien sûr
l'histoire appartient toujours en
premier lieu aux historiens et un récent
coloc à l'Assemblée nationale a permis
de faire le point sur l'état de la
recherche historique sur la question
cependant cette demande de
reconnaissance du caractère génocidaire
de Lolo de mort revêt une importance
plus symbolique dans un contexte
international que nous connaissons
ainsi en plus des demandes de soutien
financier humanitaires logistique ou
militaire cette reconnaissance certes
moins sonore que la fourniture de canon
César constituerait un vrai geste envers
le peuple ukrainien si durement frappé
par la guerre la documentation
historique de cette extermination par la
fin a longtemps été rendu difficile et
explique en partie la faible
reconnaissance jusqu'ici de ce crime de
masse
une résolution de 2003 de la Rada
ukrainienne a fait de la famine
organisée un acte génocidaire et aboutit
à la loi ukrainienne de novembre 2006
sur le Lot d'au mort
en octobre 2022 le ministre des Affaires
étrangères Ukrainiens a appelé les
parlements des nations qui soutiennent
l'Ukraine à reconnaître le caractère
génocidaire de l'eau de mort près d'une
vingtaine de pays ont jusqu'ici condamné
le mort soit comme crime contre
l'humanité soit comme génocide ainsi en
novembre dernier le Bundestag a adopté
une résolution de transpartisone
reconnaissant Lolo mort comme crime
contre l'humanité proche d'un point de
vue
historico-politique d'un génocide en
décembre c'est le Parlement européen qui
a adopté à une large majorité une
résolution considérant Lolo mort comme
un génocide du peuple ukrainien dès lors
que cette famille artificielle a été
commise par le régime soviétique dans
l'intention de détruire un groupe de
personnes en infligeant délibérément des
conditions de vie menant inexorablement
à leur anéantissement physique
le contenu de la présente PPR va dans le
même sens elle propose donc de
reconnaître officiellement le caractère
génocidaire de la famine forcée et
planifiée par les autorités soviétiques
en l'encontre de la population
ukrainienne en 1932 et 1933 et de la
condamnée publiquement la PPR a en
l'état actuel des preuves historiques
constatent le caractère intentionnel de
détruire en toute ou partie l'identité
nationale et le peuple ukrainien et plus
particulièrement la paysannerie
ukrainienne en confiscans les récoltes
les semences en intensifiant la
répression en fermant les frontières et
en instaurant un blocus des villages la
PPR demande au gouvernement de
reconnaître officiellement et de
condamner publiquement le génocide et de
poursuivre ses initiatives
pour qu'il soit plus largement reconnu
au niveau international elle encourage
enfin l'ouverture des archives portant
sur ce crime la répétition
après d'un siècle d'intervalle d'un
crime contre le peuple ukrainien doit
nous alerter elle témoigne de la
résurgence sur le sol européen de
politique de puissance qui conduisent à
nier l'existence propre des individus
comme l'identité et la culture
singulière de certains peuples par
ailleurs la répétition de crimes contre
le peuple
ukrainien doit attirer notre attention
sur la nécessité de justiciabilité des
crimes commis aujourd'hui comme hier
ainsi que du nécessaire travail de
mémoire et processus de réconciliation
pour que l'Histoire ne se répète pas
enfin la reconnaissance des crimes
contre le peuple ukrainien doit ouvrir
notre perspective sur les autres
tragédies guère ou fait partout dans le
monde ayant conduit ou conduisant à la
mort ou à la famille de millions de
personnes notamment dans les pays du Sud
afin que l'Occident ne soit pas accusé
par ces pays de maintenir des doubles
standards en matière de droit de l'homme
la reconnaissance internationale des
crimes contre le peuple ukrainien
n'aurait que plus de force pour toutes
ces raisons avec mes collègues du groupe
des députés socialistes et apparentés
nous voterons cette proposition de
résolution et je vous en remercie merci
monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-François portarieux pour
le groupe horizon apparenté et pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre sur le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères
monsieur
chez l'ambassadeur chers collègues il y
a 90 ans un génocide a été commis à
l'Ukraine un génocide qui a coûté la vie
à des millions de personnes un génocide
longtemps occulté par le pouvoir
soviétique un génocide qui est toujours
nié par le régime de Poutine
mais la vérité n'est pas une opinion et
ce génocide porte un nom le lodomores
l'extermination par la fin c'est cette
grande famine qui a frappé la République
du crâne dans l'URSS de 1932-1933
c'était bien un génocide car cette
famille n'était le fruit ni du hasard ni
d'une catastrophe naturelle
un génocide car il s'agissait bien d'un
acte meurtrier pour briser la résistance
des paysans Ukrainiens face à la
collectivisation forcée des récoltes une
politique répressive délibérée de
Staline alors que l'occasion nous est
donnée chers collègues de nommer ce
crime de masse tel qu'il est il est bon
de rappeler pourquoi nous nous devons de
le faire d'abord et avant tout pour la
mémoire des nombreuses victimes
nous le devons ensuite à tous ceux qui
voient ressurgir dans les menaces
d'aujourd'hui le spectre des crimes
d'hier il s'agit là d'une mémoire
douloureuse qu'il nous faut commémorer
ne nous y trompons pas au funeste
tableau des totalitarismes du 20e siècle
le stalinisme
occupe une place prépondérante
nous ne pouvons pas oublier les millions
de victimes de cette doctrine
totalitaire cette idéologie forgée dans
le rejet des libertés individuelles
appuyées par un système carcéral
inflexible à marquer de sa cruauté
l'histoire de tous les peuples de l'Est
de l'Europe
n'oublions pas que l'Holodomor ne fut
que l'un des nombreux crimes de ce
régime autoritaire probablement l'un des
plus ignobles
à ce génocide s'ajoute les nombreuses
familles condamnation arbitraire
assassinat exaction
souvenons-nous que 2 3 5 millions de
morts ne doit jamais rester une
statistique c'est toujours toujours une
tragédie
cette proposition de résolution envoie
un double message elle s'adresse d'abord
à ceux qui souffrent encore aujourd'hui
de l'absence de reconnaissance du
caractère génocidaire de Lolo de mort
elle s'adresse aussi à ceux qui refusent
de regarder la vérité en face et
souhaite que le souvenir de ce massacre
s'éteigne avec eux
il s'agit donc et avant tout de répondre
à l'appel des Ukrainiens qui demandent
de la reconnaissance de ce génocide
depuis de nombreuses années
le président de la Rada dukraine
renouvelée d'ailleurs cette demande ici
dans notre émission le 31 janvier
dernier
plusieurs de nos partenaires parmi nos
alliés européens les plus proches ont
reconnu ce génocide nous devons à notre
tour porter avec cette reconnaissance un
message de soutien fort au peuple
crânien
c'est ce que permet la proposition de
résolution que nous examinons
aujourd'hui à l'initiative d'anne-génété
elle reconnaît le caractère génocidaire
de cette famille organisée elle ouvre la
voie à une reconnaissance
internationale de Lolo de mort et par
extension participe à honorer la mémoire
de l'ensemble des victimes des jeunes
aussi à travers le monde le Groupe
Horizon est apparenté soutient cette
résolution et votre aura évidemment en
faveur de son adoption
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Aurélien taché
pour le groupe écologiste nu et pour 5
minutes
merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur je vais vous débuter en vous
remerciant pour ce texte dont le vote
Honorat s'est assemblée nous sommes ici
mes chers collègues pour traiter d'un
sujet d'une importance capitale celui de
la reconnaissance du caractère
génocidaire de la famille de l'odomor
mais avant d'entrer dans le vif du sujet
permettez-moi de faire un petit retour
en arrière
l'Ukraine est un pays qui a affronté
bien des crises un peuple dont la
résidence extraordinaire s'est
construite au prisme d'une histoire
aussi riche que difficile cette histoire
c'est celle de l'URSS celle de
l'indépendance celle du progressisme des
libertés et désormais celle de la guerre
cette histoire a été construite animée
par la volonté commune d'un peuple
l'autodétermination
en ce sens permettez-moi d'effectuer
deux incises historiques en 1918 alors
que l'Empire russe s'effondrait Nestor
mcno un anarchiste ukrainien a pris les
armes et organiser la résistance contre
les bolcheviks les ultrasnationalistes
et les armées étrangères le mouvement
assez réceptionnel qu'il a fondé et
devenu un symbole de résistance et de
lutte pour l'autodétermination
ukrainienne je veux aujourd'hui saluer
ce héros
quelques années plus tard sur fond de
Seconde Guerre mondiale Stéphane
bandeiras c'est lui aussi engagé dans la
lutte armée leader nationaliste il n'a
pas hésité à utiliser des méthodes
violentes saluant avec les forces de
l'Axe pour lui la cause la cause passée
avant tout quitte à sacrifier la paix et
la stabilité dans la région
en vous parlant et un antisémite vous
avez raison cher collègue en vous
parlant de ces deux personnes en réalité
je souhaite parler de méthode la liberté
des peuples peut se défendre par la
violence celle légitime de ceux qui sont
attaqués mais le remède ne doit pas être
pire que le mal la seule chose qui est
importe au fond et l'objectif celui que
nous devons tous partager la paix alors
le nationalisme comme l'impérialisme
c'est la guerre j'entends par ailleurs
ici j'entends par ailleurs ici et là
fleurir des discours expliquant que ceux
qui se passe en Ukraine ne nous concerne
pas que nous n'avons pas à prendre parti
à cela je veux répondre défendre nos
valeurs défendre la démocratie ce n'est
pas un choix c'est notre survie à tous
aucune tergiversation n'est possible
alors que certains aspects de cette
situation y compris l'influence russe
grandissante se reproduisent aujourd'hui
en Afrique il est aussi nécessaire de
nous interroger sur notre rapport au
monde et de descendre notre de notre
piédestal la sortie de la guerre
puisqu'elle arrivera et que l'Ukraine
sera victorieuse ne devra pas ouvrir un
nouveau terrain de chasse pour des
investisseurs plus intéressés par leurs
bénéfices personnels que par celui des
peuples
si une solidarité internationale doit
bien sûr s'amplifier ne reproduisons pas
les erreurs du passé abordons maintenant
le cœur de la question Lolo de mort
cette famille cette famille orchestrée
par le régime stalinien entre 1932 et
1933 représente un autre épisode sombre
de l'histoire ukrainienne ce drab un
similable à un génocide à causé la mort
de plusieurs millions d'Ukrainiens
victimes d'une politique répressive et
de confiscation des récoltes par l'État
soviétique de nombreux pays
organisations internationales ont
désigné Lolo de mort comme un génocide
et un crime contre l'humanité et il est
honorable que la France suive cette voix
les millions de personnes ayant souffert
et péril durant le lot de mort mérite
notre respect et notre souvenir en
adoptant cette résolution nous exprimons
notre solidarité avec le peuple
ukrainien et notre engagement pour un
monde plus juste plus humain la
connaissance de l'histoire est
primordiale pour que les générations
futures en saisissent les enjeux et les
enseignements en intégrant le lot de
mort dans les programmes éducatifs et en
soutenant la recherche historique nous
aiderons ainsi à éduquer nos enfants sur
les dangers du totalitarisme et c'est
possible résurgences particulièrement à
une époque où l'instant time Maïté
supporte trop souvent la mémoire la
philosophe Anna Arendt nous a enseigné
que le mal se nichait dans le vide de la
pensée ne l'oublions jamais
l'Ukraine continue de subir cette
oppression aujourd'hui tandis que les
Russes tentent de démanteler les
institutions la cohésion sociale le
système éducatif et la société
ukrainienne dans son ensemble le peuple
lui résiste le lot de mort perpétré par
les forces soviétiques au 20e siècle
réapparaît au 21ème siècle comme
l'expression la plus brutale du
totalitarisme n'ayons pas peur des mots
la guerre actuelle aussi revêt un
caractère génocidaire le peuple de
boucha homme et enfant en témoignent
victime de crimes de guerre et de
déportation les enlèvements et des
portations d'enfants qui avaient déjà
commencé avant l'invasion de février
2022 ce sont d'ailleurs intensifiés les
autorités de Kiev ont créé un site
Sheldon of War pour les recenser
comptabilisant ainsi plus de 16000
enfants concernés un mandat contre
Vladimir Poutine a été émis par la Cour
pénale internationale la place de ce
tyran est dans une cellule à la haie de
plus en prenant au lieu de culture comme
en témoigne la destruction et de pillage
depuis de 40 musées les Russes tentent
d'effacer les racines même de l'histoire
ukrainienne pourtantier étroitement liée
à la leur alors que Poutine décrivait
Kiev comme la mère de toutes les villes
russes qu'aurait-il fait sinon la
saccager s'il avait réussi à y pénétrer
on perçoit ici tout l'antagonisme et le
paradoxe du discours propre
propagandiste dont le seul mot d'ordre
est l'impérialisme enfin chers amis au
cœur de trouve au coeur de tout se
trouve la question des peuples Poutine
est un barbare mais l'Ukraine et la
Russie ne sont pas ennemis l'amitié
repose sur la reconnaissance mutuelle en
dénonçant les crimes du passé et présent
et en portant cette voie le plus haut
possible ce n'est pas le peuple russe
que nous attaquons ce sont les criminels
qui le dirigent où l'on dit où l'on
dirigé et qui les entraîne aujourd'hui
dans une guerre barbare qui ne pourront
heureusement jamais gagner je vous
remercie et vous invite donc au nom du
groupe écologiste à voter en faveur de
ce texte merci monsieur le député la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Paul Lecoq
pour le groupe gauche-démocrate et
républicaine nu et pour 5 minutes
la présidente
mes chers collègues la proposition de
résolution portant sur la reconnaissance
et la condamnation de la grande famille
de
1932-1933 comme génocide pose 6
problèmes qu'il faut mesurer ensemble
premièrement les parlementaires n'ont
pas la légitimité des historiens pour
tirer des conclusions définitives sur un
événement historique d'autant plus
lorsqu'il n'y a pas de consensus chez
les historiens eux-mêmes
c'est pourtant fondamental puisqu'il
nous est demandé de nous prononcer sur
la reconnaissance d'un génocide c'est
une décision à prendre avec toute la
solennité qui convient or nous avons
pour seul éclairage en exposé des motifs
qui manquent évidemment puisque nous ne
sommes pas historiens de cette rigueur
scientifique nécessaire pour prendre
cette décision
le deuxième problème c'est que les
parlementaires n'ont pas non plus la
légitimité pour endosser le rôle des
juges staturant sur les décisions les
dispositions de l'article 6 du Statut de
Rome qui définit un génocide
particulièrement sur la notion de
l'intention du génocidaire pour
déterminer
l'intention d'un accusé l'outil
démocratique le plus efficace dont on
dispose est un procès équitable or
n'étant ni juges historien personne ici
ne peut prétendre juger de l'intention
précise de Staline pour des faits qui
remontent à 90 ans mais si nous
condamnons en ce qui nous concerne tous
les crimes de Staline jugez ces actes
sur la grande famille nécessite de se
pencher sur les archives ouvertes il y a
une vingtaine d'années
les archives c'est le troisième problème
de cette résolution car depuis leur
ouverture la grande majorité des
historiens s'accorde à dire que ces
famines qui ont tué des millions de
citoyens soviétiques
Ukrainiens mais aussi kazak et russe
sont le résultat non intentionnelle de
décision politique administrative
erronée et appliquée de manière
déshumanisée voire criminel combiné à de
mauvaises récoltes la lecture qui
explique que cette famine a été
volontairement organisée par saline afin
de punir le nationalisme des paysans
Ukrainiens est devenu marginal chez les
historiens notamment depuis la parution
de l'ouvrage de Davis et de wickroff en
2004 sur l'agriculture soviétique qui
s'appuie sur une lecture fine des
archives et des correspondances des
dirigeants soviétiques de l'époque et
même Robert conquestre l'un des tenants
les plus reconnus de cette vision des
choses a indiqué qu'il avait abandonné
la théorie de la famille organisée après
la lecture de
la lecture que vous avez de la famille
ukrainienne présente donc un intérêt
très relatif d'un point de vue
historique votre intérêt est donc
politique or les députés du groupe GDR
refusent par principe de contribuer à la
petite à la politique des enjeux de
mémoire et d'histoire c'est le quatrième
problème de votre résolution il est
majeur faire de Lolo de mort un génocide
et l'intégrer comme un chapitre du roman
national et l'ambition du parti au
pouvoir en Ukraine mais même au
parlement ukrainien la reconnaissance de
Lolo de mort comme génocide a été voté
en 2006 à une très courte majorité
et au sein de la population
ukrainienne le sujet fait également
débat ce sujet ne fait donc même pas
consensus en Ukraine plus largement le
cinquième problème porte sur
l'utilisation du terme de génocide dans
le cadre de résolution parlementaire les
députés du groupe de la Gauche démocrate
républicaine exprime ici leur profond
malaise face à ce type de résolution
l'Assemblée nationale prend le risque de
créer une concurrence mémorielle entre
les victimes de crimes contre l'humanité
même si je suis sûr que personne ici ne
le souhaite cette concurrence aboutira
qu'on le veuille ou non à une
hiérarchisation des victimes
car si notre Assemblée a d'autres adopte
la présente résolution pourquoi la
famille
irlandaise qui a sévit entre 1845 et
1852 et qui a décimé 1 million
d'Irlandais 1 sur 8 ne serait-elle pas
un génocide après tout Londres a imposé
à Dublin en connaissance de cause de
maintenir des exportations de produits
agricoles vers l'Angleterre
et enfin le sixième problème porte sur
les enjeux diplomatiques d'un tel vote
est-il opportun de voter ce texte qui
nous rapprochera un peu plus du point de
non-retours dans nos relations avec la
Russie si nous voulons être nous
Parlement français artisan d'une pêche
juste et durable entre l'Ukraine et la
Russie il ne semble pas que le vote
d'une telle résolution soit adéquate
c'est pourquoi vous l'aurez compris nous
voterons contre cette résolution
outre-mer et territoire et pour 5
minutes
madame la Présidente je suis le monsieur
le ministre je suis le président de la
commission
chers collègues il y a 90 ans des
millions d'Ukrainiens et de Kazakhs
mourait de fin dans les campagnes de
l'Union soviétique c'est une réalité
notre présence aujourd'hui doit
permettre à la représentation nationale
de s'exprimer publiquement de la manière
la plus unanime possible sur cette
catastrophe qui malheureusement aurait
pu être évité j'aimerais revenir
rapidement comme certains de mes
collègues sur les faits après la
banqueroute américaine de 1929 les
économies dit occidentales entre en
récession l'URSS de Staline décide
d'accentuer l'exportation des céréales
afin de financer l'industrialisation de
l'économie soviétique et d'obtenir des
devises étrangères
cependant c'est denrées ne sont pas un
simple produit commercial mais sont bien
au contraire des aliments de base de la
population face aux protestations
paysannes Staline avec ces méthodes que
l'on connaît des cils alors d'accentuer
le rythme des réquisitions et de
préférer ainsi la violence commerciale à
la survie de millions de personnes mais
ce qui nous fait dire aujourd'hui que
cette répression est un génocide c'est
qu'elle est elle était guidée par la
volonté de détruire tout sentiment
national dans les républiques
soviétiques et notamment l'Ukraine
Staline n'a pas seulement décrété la
famille il a stigmatisé toute une frange
de la population des goulags et lui a
empêché de se déplacer dans les villes
et dans d'autres républiques pour
survivre entre 3 millions 5 et 5
millions de personnes sont mortes à
cause de cette folie et cette politique
d'extermination par la fin
aujourd'hui il s'agit de reconnaître le
caractère génocidaire de cette
holodomorre certains critiqueront cette
résolution en prétextant que ce n'est
pas législateur de refaire l'histoire
nous répondrons à cela que l'Assemblée
nationale représentante de l'ensemble de
l'ensemble du peuple français et
néanmoins en droit d'affirmer sa
solidarité sur un événement historique
aussi grave et nous constatons que l'eau
demeure est un acte par lequel les
autorités soviétiques avaient
l'intention de détruire tout ou partie
du peuple ukrainien on le soumettant à
des conditions d'existence devant
traîner sa destruction physique totale
ou partielle cette déclaration se fonde
sur des faits et correspond à la
définition du génocide inscrite dans la
Convention des Nations Unies pour la
prévention et la répression du génocide
en 1948
[Musique]
mais la question aujourd'hui n'est pas
celle de soutenir l'Ukraine contre
l'agression russe d'ailleurs nous
l'avons fait précisément et notre groupe
y a pris toute sa part via l'adoption
d'une résolution de novembre 2022 enfin
le lot de mort s'est produit au-delà des
frontières de l'Ukraine
votez cette résolution c'est demander
l'ouverture des archives de l'URSS sur
le sujet c'est se joindre un nombre
grandissant d'État et au Parlement
européen pour condamner l'extermination
par la famine s'est rappelé
l'attachement de notre assemblée au
devoir de mémoire alors où les faits
historiques sont manipulés et que la
liberté de travail des historiens est
entravé le gouvernement doit tout mettre
en oeuvre pour combattre les tentatives
visant à fausser les archives ou à
manipuler l'opinion publique sur ce qui
s'est réellement passé entre 1933 et
1933 dès lors
que certains troncs la vérité il est
important que notre assemblée affirme
clairement un récit basé sur des faits
et des preuves pour toutes ces raisons
le groupe liberté indépendant outre-mer
et territoire votera la résolution
portant sur la reconnaissance et la
condamnation de Lolo de mort je vous en
remercie
merci monsieur le Président la parole
est à Madame Emmanuel Ménard pour les
non inscrits pour 5 minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues
la famille comme arme de guerre comme
solution finale le grenier à blé de
l'URSS transformé en cimetière des
affamés cette famille impitoyable de
1932 1933 a été orchestré organisé
planifier par un pouvoir soviétique
cruel vorace
assassins qui voulait piller et asservir
l'Ukraine
4 millions certains avancent un chiffre
encore plus important 4 millions
d'Ukrainiens principalement des paysans
qui furent alors condamnés à la famine
et à la mort
dissimuler aux yeux du monde cette
tragédie est restée désespérément tabou
pendant des décennies alors ou des
millions de paysans périssaient
condamnés à mort par un régime qui
voulait briser leur résistance le
journal l'Humanité affirmait en août
1933 aveuglé ou complices il n'y a pas
de famine en Ukraine ni dans aucune
République ou région de l'Union
soviétique mais la campagne
antisoviétique fait rage parce que
l'URSS a déjoué tous les plans
d'agression parce que sa puissance
grandit parce que sa politique de paix
enregistre des succès retentissants
la politique de paix qui nous rappelle
la République des descendants de ces
staliniens qui manifestent aujourd'hui
encore contre la guerre en Ukraine ou
plutôt disons-le clairement contre
l'armement du peuple ukrainien toujours
les mêmes complices
extermination par la fin en ukrainien a
depuis été longuement documenté Nicolas
verte dans son Livre noir du communisme
la décrit ainsi une famille très méditée
organisée systématisé destiné à éliminer
la partie la plus dynamique de la
paysannerie il faut appeler ça un
génocide de classe en 2004 l'arrivée au
pouvoir de Victor hutchenko après la
Révolution orange a été l'occasion pour
les Ukrainiens de dénoncer enfin la
barbarie des actes commandités par
Staline élevée au rang de tragédie
nationale est reconnu comme génocide en
2006 par le Parlement Lolo de mort est
aujourd'hui commémoré sur le sol
ukrainien mais tard encore à être
reconnu par les autres nations comme un
génocide à part entière les États-Unis
ou la Pologne eux l'ont fait il y a plus
de 15 ans l'Allemagne et le Parlement
européen en novembre et décembre dernier
s'il nous a fallu aussi longtemps pour
que nous nous saisissions de cette
question une proposition de loi avait
été déposée en 2006 par un député
Christian Vanneste qui n'a jamais été
examiné de ce génocide par la fin c'est
j'en suis persuadé que le communisme a
bénéficié d'un traitement différent des
autres totalitarisme qui ont défiguré le
20e siècle
100 millions de morts pourtant
aujourd'hui encore certains s'en
revendiquent imaginez un instant qu'un
parti dans cet assemblée se réclame du
fascisme ou du nazisme nous ne pourrions
pas le tolérer et à juste raison mais se
définir comme communiste après le goulag
polpote la révolution culturelle ou la
chasse aux homosexuels chez Castro ne
semble ne semble pas troubler certains
oui j'en suis persuadé il nous faut un
Nuremberg du communisme il nous faut
regarder en face cette monstruosité qui
au nom de la dictature du prolétariat et
de la lutte des classes a emprisonné
torturer tu es massacré exterminé en
Ukraine on vient de le voir mais aussi
en URSS et dans les pays d'Europe de
l'Est sous sa coupe et aujourd'hui
encore en Chine à Cuba ou en Corée du
Nord un Nuremberg du communisme qui nous
permet de faire la lumière sur toutes
ces atrocités de tenter de comprendre
pourquoi tant de nos intellectuels ont
cautionné ces crimes pourquoi en 1989
encore un George marcher pouvait
affirmer que le bilan des pays de l'Est
était globalement positif sans que cela
ne déclenche un tolé général la
mansuétude dont a bénéficier le
communisme est impardonnable et ceux qui
s'abritent derrière le fait qu'ils ne
savaient pas sont des menteurs la haine
la violence du communisme nous les
voyons encore à l'oeuvre dans la haine
la violence des discours et des actes
d'une extrême gauche qui ne rêvent que
de chaos d'incendie notre société et de
tuer nos policiers
cette rhétorique mortifère et pour
paraphraser certains toujours présente
dans le ventre encore fécond de la bête
immonde qu'a été et qui est toujours le
communisme oui le communisme est une
bête immonde et pas seulement le nazisme
le fascisme le racisme ou
l'antisémitisme comme nous l'explique
Wikipédia il n'y a pas un totalitarisme
plus excusable que les autres Lolo de
mort devrait être l'occasion de le
rappeler à la phase de tous en mémoire
de toutes ces victimes et en hommage au
vivant qui continue de se battre chaque
jour contre la Russie pour une liberté
qui est aussi la nôtre je vous remercie
merci
la discussion générale est close la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier best
ministre délégué chargé du Commerce
extérieur de l'attractivité et des
Français de l'étranger
[Applaudissements]
mesdames la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés et tout
particulièrement madame la députés
enjoyente qui était à l'origine de la
première signature de cette proposition
de résolution
la résolution qui est aujourd'hui
soumise à l'examen de cette assemblée
revêt une importance toute particulière
non seulement parce que la mémoire de la
grande famille ukrainienne de
1932-1933 dit au lot de mort et devenu
un élément central de l'identité du pays
mais aussi parce que les souffrances
alors endurer par le peuple ukrainien
font écho à celles qu'il subit
aujourd'hui
d'hier a aujourd'hui en effet la
détermination dont la nation ukrainienne
fait preuve au cours de l'histoire force
notre admiration
ce texte est également important car il
souligne l'envergure de ce crime de
masse qui est le lot de mort rester
longtemps méconnu en raison de la
volonté des autorités soviétiques de
dissimuler les preuves pourtant
évidentes attestant de leur implication
dans son organisation
il a ainsi fallu attendre l'arrivée au
pouvoir de Michael Gorbatchev pour que
la vérité se fasse progressivement jour
grâce au travail des historiens qui à
partir de l'exploitation des archives
ont mis en lumière la réalité du projet
soviétique
celui-ci ne visait rien moins que
l'écrasement d'un ennemi intérieur
fantasmé le kulac paysan possédant que
le régime considérait également comme le
représentant d'un nationalisme ukrainien
cherchant à saboter sa politique de
collectivisation forcée
pour atteindre ce but le régime a
recouru aux amandes au confiscations des
moindres réserves de nourriture mais
aussi au blocus de village entier fuyant
à la famine et au déportation collective
cette répression
implacable a fait plusieurs millions de
victimes
la résolution que vous examinez
aujourd'hui revêt aussi une situation
tout particulière en raison de sa
résonance évidente avec l'actualité la
Russie est aujourd'hui engagée dans une
fuite en avant qu'il a conduit à
instrumentaliser et à réécrire
l'histoire afin de nourrir un récit
national justifiant ses ambitions
impérialistes et sa guerre d'agression
contre l'Ukraine elle pousse la
manipulation des événements jusqu'à la
dénégation de la réalité de l'Ukraine
comme peuple et comme nation
face à ces agissements la France
poursuit son soutien au travail
indispensable des historiens je pense
notamment au programme que nos unités
mixtes de recherche en France et à
l'étranger ont mis en place avec
l'Ukraine en histoire et en sciences
sociales
l'attachement à la vérité objective des
faits historiques et la marque des
nations démocratiques
la dernière commémoration de Lolo de
mort le 26 novembre dernier a rappelé
avec une acuité toute particulière que
la Russie aggrave par sa guerre
d'invasion
l'insécurité alimentaire mondiale
dont de nombreux États souffrent
aujourd'hui
n'ayons pas peur des mots
la Russie n’hésite pas à prendre en
otage l'accès de millions de personnes à
des céréales pourtant essentiels à leur
survie elle montre avec une régularité
en un sens remarquable tous les trois
mois lorsqu'il s'agit de renouveler
l'accord sur l'exploitation des grains
par la mer Noire qu'elle est prête à
tout pour renforcer les leviers dont
elle pense disposées pour appuyer son
agression
là encore la France a agi avec
détermination le président de la
République avait annoncé à cette
occasion le soutien de la France à
l'initiative green
lancé par le président zeninski qui
s'était très concrètement traduit par
une contribution supplémentaire de 6
millions d'euros pour le transport et la
distribution par le Programme
alimentaire mondial de céréales
d'Ukraine à destination du Yémen et du
Soudan
à travers cette proposition de
résolution transpartisale mesdames et
messieurs les députés vous vous
inscrivez dans ce travail de
reconnaissance d'un crime indéniable
il est certes pas dans les habitudes du
gouvernement de reconnaître comme
génocide des faits qui n'ont pas
préalablement été qualifiés comme tel
par une juridiction qu'elle soit
française ou internationale mais la
réalité des crimes commis lors de Lolo
de mort ne fait pas de doute et c'est
pourquoi le Gouvernement soutient ce
texte par ailleurs
je tiens à redire ici le soutien
constant et indéfectible de la France à
l'Ukraine pour l'aider à se défendre
contre cette agression illégale
injustifiable et à justifier pour
l'aider à préserver sa liberté et son
intégrité territoriale mais également
l'aider à tenir face au bombardement
russe qui vise sa population et ses
infrastructures
au-delà des livraisons d'équipements
militaires notre soutien vient répondre
à l'ensemble des besoins exprimés par
Kiev aide économique et financière aide
humanitaire aide matérielle la France et
l'Union européenne se tiennent avec
détermination aux côtés de l'Ukraine
ils apporteront leur soutien aussi
longtemps qu'il sera nécessaire
car face à une Russie qui multiplie les
exactions au point que son président est
aujourd'hui visé par un mandat d'arrêt
de la Cour pénale internationale
face à une Russie qui ne montre aucune
ouverture pour la négociation et le
dialogue et des l'Ukraine à résister et
à reprendre l'ascendant et la meilleure
manière de mettre un terme au conflit la
France agit donc concrètement pour ne
pas laisser les crimes du passé sous
silence pas plus qu'elle ne tolère
l'impunité de ce aujourd'hui commis par
la Russie sur le sol ukrainien soyez
assurés mesdames et messieurs les
députés que nous continuerons à agir en
ce sens aux côtés de l'Ukraine je vous
remercie merci monsieur le ministre
je vous informe que sur la proposition
de résolution je suis saisie par le
groupe renaissance d'une demande de
scrutin public que j'annonce dans
l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale et
je vous indique également à avoir reçu
des demandes d'explication de vote sur
cette elles sont de droite sur cette
proposition de résolution la parole est
à Madame angente pour le groupe
Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
merci maintenant Présidente je vais être
extrêmement brève vous l'aurez compris
le comprenais sens soutient cette
proposition de résolution je voudrais
juste rappeler en quelques mots les
dernières phrases de mon discours
certains de mes collègues n'avaient pas
pu être là votez pour cette résolution
c'est aussi confirmé aux Français aux
Européens et au monde que lorsque les
valeurs essentielles et universelles
sont en jeu il n'y a plus ni majorité ni
minorité ni centre ni droite ni gauche
mais une Assemblée nationale composée de
femmes et d'hommes qui représentent la
Nation toute entière et qui réunit dans
un même élan d'humanité vote en
conscience alors ne regardons plus
ailleurs vive l'Ukraine libre et votons
cette résolution ainsi madame la députée
la parole est à Monsieur Alexis Corbière
pour le groupe la France insoumise non
d'accord la parole est à au président
bourlange pour le groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
nos
collègues du Bundes Stagg nos collègues
du Parlement européen ont voté des
résolutions allant dans le sens de la
reconnaissance du caractère génocidaire
des massacres connus sous le nom de
domaine avons-nous des raisons de nous
distinguer d'eux nous ne le pensons pas
et j'espère que nous ne le ferons pas
nous ne le pensons pas car les éléments
constitutifs du génocide sont réunis
l'intentionnalité criminelle est
évidente le caractère massif
systématique non individualisé des
crimes est évident le critère
territorial de sélection des victimes
est évident nous sommes en présence d'un
crime qui a frappé des gens qui étaient
sur le territoire
ukrainien parce qu'ils étaient sur le
territoire ukrainien parce qu'ils
étaient
ukrainiens et pour aucune autre raison
ça c'est un génocide alors monsieur
Monsieur Le Coq nous dit nous ne sommes
pas des historiens il a raison mais les
historiens ont fait le travail mais
l'histoire ne juge pas contrairement à
ce qu'on dit les historiens ont fait le
travail nous avons les faits nous les
connaissons et c'est à nous responsable
politique d'apprécier moralement la
qualification de ces faits monsieur
monsieur Lecoq nous dit nous ne sommes
pas des juges là encore il a raison mais
nous sommes des responsables politiques
c'est-à-dire ceux qui fixent les normes
au nom desquels les juges doivent agir
en revanche Monsieur Le Coq nous sommes
des responsables politiques ça veut dire
que nous avons une conscience morale de
nos responsabilités nous savons en face
de quoi nous sommes et ce que nous
savons c'est qu'il y a
d'innombrables décennies nos pays nos
opinions publiques ont fait preuve d'une
incroyable
présence à l'égard de ces crimes
rappelez-vous que quand on traversait
l'Ukraine ont baissé les stores pour ne
pas voir ces crimes parce que les
Soviétiques ne voulaient pas qu'on sache
qui se passe on a toléré tout ça et bien
aujourd'hui nous le tolérons pas parce
que nous ne voulons pas que ça
recommence et que les intentions
génocidaires qui sont à l'oeuvre dans
l'Ukraine d'aujourd'hui puis se
prévaloir de notre silence ou de notre
complaisance
merci le monsieur le Président la parole
est au président Vallot
oui merci madame la Présidente
a fort bien dit les choses
il s'agit pas de dire ce qu'est
l'histoire les faits sont aujourd'hui
assez bien établis et nous avions il y a
quelques jours à peine organisé ici avec
agent Tai beaucoup d'entre vous une
conférence ou les meilleurs spécialistes
du sujet se sont exprimés je voudrais
dire que après l'Allemagne après le
Parlement européen que l'Assemblée
nationale française reconnaît sa son
tour le caractère génocidaire de l'eau
de mort nous au nord je veux dire aussi
que la justice
ukrainienne puisque c'est aussi de
reconnaissance juridique qu'il s'agit
c'est prononcer en faveur de la
reconnaissance de l'eau de mort comme un
génocide je crois que c'est évidemment
un acte politique au sens où nous
prenons notre responsabilité de graver
ce que sont des faits historiques dans
une délibération des représentants de la
nation au moment où parmi les armes
déployées par Vladimir Poutine il y a
cette tentative forcenée violente
de réécrire l'histoire à son profit et à
son bénéfice et de dire avec nos amis
Ukrainiens de la façon la plus
solennelle qui soit avec beaucoup de
Parlement européens que la vérité
historique ne se gomme pas à coup de
ruchâtelet ou d'autres outils de
propagande je crois cela
particulièrement nécessaire c'est une
façon de dire aussi qu'ici la cause
ukrainienne ne sera pas chassé balayé
par une autre actualité dont nous
pourrions nous saisir également mais que
nous continuerons de la faire vivre
parce qu'il en va en réalité de la
justice
merci monsieur le Président la parole
est à Monsieur Aurélien taché pour le
groupe écolo Nupe
merci madame la Présidente comme je l'ai
dit dans mon discours le peuple
ukrainien a eu plus que d'autres à se
battre pour son auto-détermination il a
eu plus que d'autres à se battre contre
les impérialismes l'impérialisme
soviétique à une époque l'impérialisme
de Poutine aujourd'hui la résolution que
l'on doit voter aujourd'hui vise à
reconnaître finalement le caractère
génocidaire de cette holodomie et elle
est d'autant plus importante que nous
l'avons pas dit dans nos échanges mais à
l'époque un certain herio président du
conseil de cette assemblée français a
tout fait pour minimiser finalement le
caractère génocidaire de Lolo de mort je
le dis que ce vote est aussi important
parce que la guerre que même Poutine
actuellement revêt elle aussi un
caractère génocidaire mais attention
chers collègues ne nous trompons pas si
cette résolution est résolument
anti-impérialiste elle n'est pas
anti-communiste et nous la voterons pas
rentier impérialisme nous écologistes et
certainement pas pour comme à la droite
de cette assemblée faire de
l'instrumentalisation politicienne sur
la question du communisme merci
monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Paul Lecoq pour le groupe
GDR nu
merci madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues
heureux sont ceux qui détiennent la
vérité absolue
ce n'est pas notre cas nous ne la
connaissons pas nous l'assumons nous
nous questionnons nous cherchons nous
essayons d'avoir comme souvent vous le
faites y compris au gouvernement une
vérité scientifique et nous avons
cherché cette vérité scientifique et
comme il y a le doute et comme sur
plusieurs résolutions qui sont venues
dans cette hémicycle et qui ne parlaient
pas
[Musique]
je vais laisser monsieur balalan
terminer sa phrase
et comme il y a le doute
nous considérons
de considérons que le caractère génod
génocidaire n'est pas avérée c'est notre
choix ceci dit lorsque j'ai entendu
madame Ménard
je me suis dit que peut-être la vérité
sortait de sa bouche
que peut-être en fait
le moment où sort cette résolution et il
y a eu beaucoup de lapsus révélateur y
compris en commission des affaires
étrangères une fois un vice-président de
la commission il y a dans le précédent
mandat avait dit il reste encore deux
grands pays communistes dans le monde et
il citer la Chine et la Russie comme
quoi on n'était pas sortis encore de
cette anticommunisme et peut-être madame
Ménard vous pensez que Poutine et
l'héritier de Staline mais s'il vous
plaît ne nous associez pas ne nous
associer pas nous communiste français et
la façon dont vous l'avez dit vous
associez les communistes français comme
des descendants du criminel Staline et
nous ne l'acceptons pas les communistes
français sont les descendants du parti
des fusillés les communistes français
sont les descendants des membres du
Conseil National de la Résistance ce
sont ceux-là les communistes français et
donc ne mélangez pas les choses nous
avons une position vous l'avez mesuré
compliqué à tenir et nous l'assumons
mais aujourd'hui aujourd'hui nous
assumons notre considération sur le
caractère génocidaire nous reconnaissons
les crimes de masse nous reconnaissons
les crimes contre l'humanité de Staline
dans le lot de mort nous ne
reconnaissons pas le caractère
génocidaire uniquement ça et c'est ce
qui fait notre vote contre sur ce terme
et pas sur les autres voilà ce que je
voulais dire merci monsieur le député
alors je n'ai pas d'autres demandes
d'explication de vote donc je vais
mettre au voie la proposition de
résolution le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
votant 170 exprimés 170 majorité 86 168
votes pour et 2 contre l'Assemblée
nationale a adopté
[Applaudissements]